season 11 of halloween wars kicks off
this sunday on food network and we have
a las vegas resident on the show it's
holly webster hi great to see you happy
to be here okay what is the show all
about someone hasn't seen halloween wars
what's the show about halloween wards is
a huge deal it's one of food network's
best rated holiday shows
it's the 11th season
but we all get together we're all we
have different mediums so there's sugar
artist chocolate artists there's cake
artists and
we all come together and we try to get
the grand prize and you're you're making
halloween themed decorations we're gonna
start making that something right here
what are we making what do we put
together we're gonna get in the holiday
mood and we are gonna make some
halloween cupcakes now as we make these
halloween cupcakes zach baggins is on
the show this season tell me about that
our very own local celebrities zach
bagan showed up on screen we had no idea
and he is a co-host and it was really
awesome but all of the episodes are
actually predicated they are inspiration
from his haunted museum he has that that
haunted dirt in his museum from the lake
the world's most possessed house he has
the dirt from the basement yeah that
might be one of the themes where you got
to kind of make something around that oh
yeah it's crazy because it's super
creepy so the first episode
is about possessed toys so we had to
make something according to possession
possess toys uh holly you're gonna be
sticking around for the rest of the show
we kind of have to wrap it up here we'll
come back and finish our creation okay
i'm working on something here okay you
stick around the show is going to be so
much fun we can't wait to see it on
sunday night halloween wars airs on food
network this sunday at 6 p.m and again
we'll check in with holly later on in
the show rocky